Jesus News top-5
[Music]
last week Eddie we talked about vampires
but now coal Judy's going all in on
zombies why not right I mean zombies are
the most popular thing in call of duty
so bringing them back it's time for
black ops three is getting new DLC
called zombies Chronicles it's going to
include eight remastered maps from past
Treyarch developed games so world at war
black ops and black ops 2 some of the
maps are ascension from black ops and
then brooked abrupt can't say German
where nobody came I apologize
nada from from world at war so a lot of
great maps they're remastered we haven't
quite seen them in action yet but they
said there's a reveal further reveal
coming on May 8th and then releasing on
ps4 and May 16th so very very soon
coming to Xbox one and PC sometime later
Eddie the ever quotable Hideo Kojima
came out this week with another
fantastic box pop he said he wanted
first of all people to see a naked
Norman in regards to death stranding is
that not true of everyone I mean that's
just life in general I've always wanted
to see a naked Norman when I wake up in
the morning that sounds like a euphemism
to me he also spoke about the tests
they've been doing on the decimal engine
which was it had just been used for
horizon zero dawn because it was built
by Guerrilla Games I believe he spoke
about how they've built a New York
restaurant test scene and they're
running through who Norman Reedus is
character is going to talk to in there
whether or not he'll be wearing clothes
who knows but it sounds like it's quite
early in development right but he has
previously said I think was a TGS that
it might come out in 2018 but I don't
know another thing he said there to was
talking about his desire to make a movie
mean if you follow him on Twitter you
know he loves movies or if you played a
metal gear right yeah which is
essentially food yeah he was asked and
he said yes I would love to you know
someday but absolutely not until you
know just ranting comes out he says he
has some ideas he doesn't want to adapt
one of his games he wants to try
something totally new so as long as it
has Mads in it yeah well yeah it's got
imagine another massive game drops this
week ahead of a three and now we know
we're getting dark side is three which
is super exciting Lily being made by a
team at formed from the ashes of digital
games which was was making the games
earlier Darksiders one ducks under
yeah so back from those games were
coming out in 2010 and 2012 finally
we're looking to get Darksiders 3 which
is going to star fury she's taking on
the seven deadly sins this time around
who are ravaging the earth because of
course they are and yeah it's due to
come out they reckon sometime in 2018
according to a leaked Amazon listing
although the listing puts in a date of
December 31 so maybe not 2018 we'll
cross our fingers on that one while you
wait for that too
Darksiders wanted to were both half off
right now on all platforms so good time
to jump back in yes Dan turn around I
don't know man I reckon there's a core
off back there you know how I'd find it
I'd equip the new core of Mars coming
out to zeldo breath of the wild in the
first DLC pack what segue not only can
you get a croc mask you can also you
dress up like single the creepiest and
best character ever made in video games
why would you not want to do that what
else is it there's also majora's mask
mask then you can dress up as no no min
de Mendoza be there the Phantom's from
Phantom Hourglass as well as some armor
for them but obviously the costume
that's what I'm excited about but the
main part that most damned is going to
be interested in is the meat of it the
hard mode that's coming hard mode yeah
so enemies in the wild are going to
become you know more difficult those
with me master also you start with no
equipment and you've got a work your way
through a wave defense mode slowly
getting equipment and if you get all the
way to the end you unlock the true
potential of the Master Sword I don't
know what that means
you start almost completely naked which
ties back to what we were talking about
earlier yeah yeah I make it moment also
there's the hero's path which will show
although everywhere you've walked around
Hyrule on your map for your 200 hours of
playtime I feel like Nintendo haven't
really thought this through because I
reckon it's going to take maybe I'm in
it before someone draws big penis and
speaking of hero's path and walking
around Hyrule there is a new treasure
Corbett there's medallion sorry called
the traveling medallion of course sorry
called the travelers medallion it lets
you set a warp point wherever you're
standing and then from anywhere in the
world you can walk back to there but you
can only set one Waypoint in one time
and that is only the first expansion
pack so there's a second one coming out
this holiday that is the story one so if
you're more interested in seeing what's
next the story that's the one to look
forward to 7m semi name you're actually
kind of crazy and call me baby wants
unchanged I love the average tree
connections between the story which
talking about and whatever you've
decided you know what the connection is
it's destiny to Activision Blizzard in
an earnings call has spoken about
destiny to SPC versions and it's going
to have custom features for the PC they
also talked about how pre-orders are go
and question run for destiny too and
that they do still have a plan for
constant content updates after it comes
out and they're going to utilize other
Triple A developers to bring out that
content at a steady pace stuff like
Vicarious Visions are working on it okay
so you made Tony Hawk so maybe we'll
have some Jessica skateboard kickflips
it'd be pretty sweet
and also another Activision Blizzard
news and I know you love this game
overwatch it is blizzards eight billion
dollar franchise that's a chunk of
change it is quite a lot more money than
we'll ever see in our lifetime mm-hmm
mm-hmm
we should make overwatch well then we
would make it work enough
we should make overwatch the conclusions
mr. Torre hey Dan hey Jessica you made
afraid to this thing
sure do they can find on GameSpot yeah
you can watch my feature on hack net and
why it's one of the best PC games you
haven't played and you also made a
feature this week just did I made the
third video on things you can find that
might help you out in persona because I
played for sonar for too much of my life
and I figured it can help these guys out
that is it for us this week and next
week I'm taking a bit of a break from
you don't worry I'll be back week after
next but Dan is going to be taking care
of you so at least you have that sucked
in no it's nice you'll be nice for them
o mio babbino everyone will be nice to
each other I'll be nice okay why is your
solution always to run from the camera
if you can't think of an actress where
he do